thanks for being here
five of
2:30 today we have the chance to to host
a guest speaker Pranav reporter who is a
PhD student in computer science advised
by Professor Android and professor Percy
Liang so Pranab is is working on AI and
high impact projects specifically
related to healthcare and natural
language processing and today he is
going to to present an overview of AI
for healthcare and he's going to dig
into some projects he has led through
case studies so don't hesitate to
interact I think we have a lot to learn
from Pranav and he's really an industry
expert for AI for healthcare and I let
you the mic run off thanks for being
here thanks Karen thanks for inviting me
can you hear me at the back is the mic
on alright fantastic well really glad to
be here so I want to cover three things
today
the first is give you a sort of broad
overview of what AI applications in
healthcare look like the second is bring
you three case studies from the lab that
I'm in as demonstrations of AI and
healthcare research and then finally
some ways that you can get involved if
you're interested in applying AI to high
impact problems in healthcare or if
you're from a healthcare background as
well let's start with the first so one
way we can decompose the kinds of things
I can do in healthcare is by trying to
formulate levels of questions that we
can ask from data at the lowest level
are what are descriptive questions here
we're really trying to get at what
happened then there are diagnostic
questions where we're asking why did it
happen if a patient had chest pains
I took their x-ray what is that chest
x-ray show if they have palpitations
what is their ECG show then their
predictive problems
sure I care about asking about the
future what's going to happen in the
next six months and then at the highest
level our prescriptive problems here I'm
really trying to ask okay I know this is
the patient this is the symptoms they're
coming in with this is how their
trajectory will look like in terms of in
terms of things that may happen that
their risk off what should I do and this
is the real action point and that's I
would say the the goldmine but to get
there requires a lot of data and a lot
of steps and we'll talk a little bit
more about that so in CS 2:30 you're all
well aware of the paradigm shift of deep
learning and if we look at machine
learning in healthcare literature we see
that has a very similar pattern is that
we had this feature extraction engineer
who was responsible for getting from the
input to a set of features that a
classifier can understand and the deep
learning paradigm is to combine feature
extraction and the classification into
one step by automatically extracting
features which is cool here's what I
think will be the next paradigm shift
for AI in healthcare but also more
generally is we still have a deep
learning engineer up here that's you
that's me that are designing the
networks that are making decisions like
a convolutional neural network is the
best architecture for this problem the
specific type of architecture there's an
RN and CN n and whatever NN you can
throw on there but what if we could just
replace out the ml engineer as well and
I find this quite funny because everyone
you know in AI for healthcare question
that I get asked a lot is are we going
to replace doctors with all these AI
solutions and nobody actually realizes
that we might replace machine learning
engineers faster than we might replace
doctors of this earth this to be the
case
a lot of research is developing
algorithms that can automatically learn
architecture some of what you might go
through in this class great so that's
the general overview now I want to talk
about three case studies in the lab of
AI being applied to different problems
and because healthcare is so broad I
thought I'd focus in on one narrow
vertical and let us go deep on that and
that's medical imaging so I've chosen
three problems and one of them's a 1b
problem the second is a 2d problem as
and the third is a-- is it 3d problem so
I thought we could we can walk through
all the different kinds of data here so
this is some work that was done early
last year in the lab where we showed
that we were able to detect arrhythmias
at the level of cardiologists so
arrhythmias are an important problem
affect millions of people this has
especially come to light recently with
devices like the Apple watch which now
have a ECG monitoring and the thing
about this is that sometimes you might
have symptoms and know that you have
arrhythmias but other times you may not
have symptoms and still have arrhythmias
that can be addressed with with if if
you were to do an ECG and the ECGs test
is basically showing the heart's
electrical activity over time the
electrodes are attached the skin-safe
tests and it takes over a few minutes
and this is what it looks like when
you're hooked up to all the different
electrodes so this test is often done
for a few minutes in the hospital and
the finding is basically that in a few
minutes you can't really capture a
person's of normal heart rhythms so
let's send them home for 24 to 48 hours
with a holter monitor and let's see what
we can find there are more recent
devices such as the Zeo patch which let
let patients be monitored for up to two
weeks and it's it's quite
convenient you can use it in the shower
or while you're sleeping so you really
can capture a lot of what what's
happening in the hearts ECG activity but
if we look at the amount of data that's
generated in two weeks it's one point
six million heartbeats that's a lot and
there are very few doctors who'd be
willing to go through two weeks of ECG
reading for each of their patients and
this really motivates why we need
automated interpretation here but
automated detection comes with a
challenges one of them is you know you
have in the hospital several electrodes
and in more recent devices we have just
one and the way one can think of several
electrodes is sort of the electrical
activity of the heart is 3d and each one
of the electrodes is giving a different
2d perspective into the 3d perspective
but now that we have only one lead we
only have one of these perspectives
available and the second one is that the
differences between the heart rhythms
are very subtle this is what a cardiac
cycle looks like and when we're looking
at arrhythmias or normal heart rhythms
one's going to look at the sub
structures within the cycle and then
this the structure between cycles as
well and the differences are quite
subtle so when we started working on
this problem oh maybe I should share
this story so we started working on this
problem and then it was me my my
collaborator on e and and professor Inge
and one of the things that he that he
mentioned we should do he said let's
just go out and read ECG books and let's
do the exercises and if you're in med
school they're these books where where
you can where you can learn about ECG
interpretation and then there are
several exercises that you can do to
test yourselves so I went to the med
school library you know they have those
hand crank
shouts at the bottom see if to move them
and then grab my book and then we went
for two weeks and did learn sir did go
through two books and learn ECG
interpretation and it was pretty
challenging and if we looked at previous
literature to this I think they were
sort of drawing upon some domain
knowledge er in that here we're looking
at waves how can we extract specific
features from waves that doctors are
also looking at so there was a lot of
feature engineering going on and if
you're familiar with wavelet transforms
they were this sort of they were the
most common approach with a lot of sort
of like different mother wavelets etc
etc pre-processing bandpass filters so
everything you can imagine doing what
signals was done and then you fed it
into your SVM and you called it a day
now with deep learning we can change
things up a bit
so on the Left we have an ECG signal and
on the right is just three heart rhythms
we're gonna call them a B and C and
we're gonna learn the mapping to go
straight from the input to the output
and here's how we're gonna break it out
we're gonna say that every label labels
the same amount of the signal so if we
had four labels and the ECG would be
split into these four sort of this
rhythm is labeling this part and then
we're going to use a deep neural network
so we've built a 1d convolutional neural
network which runs over the time
dimension of the input because remember
we're getting one scalar over over time
and then this architecture is 34 layers
deep so I thought I'd talk a little bit
about the architecture have you seen
resonance before okay so should I go
into this okay cool here's my 1-minute
spiel of ResNet then is that your going
deeper in terms of the number of layers
that your
having in a network you should be able
to represent a larger set of functions
but when we look at the training error
for these very deep networks what we
find is that it's worse than a smaller
network now this is not the validation
error this is the training error that
means even with the ability to represent
a more complex function we aren't able
to represent the training data so the
motivating idea of residual networks is
to say hey let's add shortcuts within
network so as to minimize the distance
from the error signal to each of my
layers this is just math to say the same
thing so further work on ResNet showed
that ok we have the shortcut connection
how should we make information flow
through it the best and the finding was
basically that anything you you add to
the shortcut to the highway think of
these as stop signs or or or signals on
a highway and it's basically saying the
fastest way on the highways to not have
anything but addition on it and then
there were a few advancements on top of
that like adding dropout and increasing
the number of filters in the
convolutional neural network that we
also added to this network okay so
that's the convolutional neural network
let's talk a little bit about data so
one thing that was cool about this
project was that we got to partner up
with a with a startup that manufactures
these hardware patches and we got data
off of patients who were wearing these
patches for up to two weeks and this was
from around 30,000 patients and this is
600 times bigger than the largest data
set that that was out there before and
for each of these ECG signals what
happened
is that each of them is annotated by a
clinical ECG expert who says here's
where rhythm a starts and here's where
ends so let's mark the whole ECG that
way obviously very time-intensive
but a good data source and then we had a
test set as well and here we use here we
use a committee of cardiologists so
they'd get together sit in a room and
decide ok we disagree on the specific
point let's try to let's try to discuss
which one of us is right or what this
rhythm actually is so they arrive at a
ground truth after discussion and then
we can of course test cardiologists as
well and the way we do this is we have
them do it individually so this is not
the same set that did the ground truth
there's a different set of cardiologists
coming in one at a time you tell me
what's going on here and we're going to
test you so when we compared the
performance of our algorithm to
cardiologists we found that we were able
to surpass them on the f1 metrics so
this is precision and recall and when we
looked at where the mistakes were made
we can see that sort of the the biggest
mistake was between distinguishing two
rhythms which look very very similar but
actually don't have a difference in in
in treatment here's another case where
the model is not making a mistake which
the experts are making and turns out
this is a costly mistake this is saying
a benign heart rhythm or what experts
thought was a benign heart rhythm was
actually a pretty serious one so that's
that's one beauty of automation is that
we're able to catch these catch these
misdiagnosis
here are three hard blocks which are
clinically irrelevant to catch on which
the model outperforms the experts and on
atrial fibrillation which is probably
the most common serious arrhythmia the
same pulse
one of the things that's neat about this
application a lot of applications in
health care is what automation with deep
learning machine learning enables is for
us to be able to continuously monitor
patients and this is not something we've
been able to do before so a lot of even
science of understanding how patients
risk factors what they are or how they
change hasn't been done before and this
is an exciting opportunity to be able to
advance science as well and the Apple
watch has recently released their their
ECG monitoring and it'll be exciting to
see what new things we can find out
about at the health of our hearts from
from these inventions okay so that was
our first question yeah so repeat the
question how was it to to sort of deal
with data privacy and sort of keep
patients information private so in in
this case we did not have we had
completely de-identified data so it was
just some was ECG signal without any
extra information about their their
clinical records or anything like that
so it's it's very it's very you have
like it like signed off that's credible
Authority you're like total hospitals
I'm getting that to be oh sure and I
think we can we can take this question
offline as well but one of the beauties
of working at Stanford is that there's a
lot of Industry research collaborations
and we have great infrastructure to be
able to work with that so which brings
me on to my second case study sorry yeah
go for it
that's a good question so just to repeat
the question how did we define a gold
standard when we have experts setting
the gold standard so here's how we did
it so one one way to come up with the
gold standard is to say okay if we
looked at what a consensus would say
what would they say and so we got three
cardiologists in a room to set the gold
standard and then to compare the
performance of experts these were
individuals who were separate from those
groups of cardiologists who sat in
another room and said what they thought
of the of the ECG signals that way
there's there's some disagreement where
the gold standard is set by the
committee great so here we looked at how
we can detect pneumonia off of chest
x-rays so pneumonia is an infection that
affects millions in the u.s. it's big
global burden is actually in in kids so
that's where it's really useful to be
able to detect that automatically and
well so to detect pneumonia there's a
chest x-ray exam and chest x-rays are
the most common imaging procedure with
two billion chest x-rays done per year
and the way of normalities are detected
in chest x-rays is they present as areas
of increased density so where things
should appear dark they appear brighter
or vice-versa
and here's what characteristically
pneumonia looks like where it's like a
fluffy cloud but this is an
oversimplification of course because
pneumonia is when the alveoli fill up
with pus
the alveoli can fill up with a lot of
other things as well which lead to very
different interpretations and diagnosis
for the patients and treatment for the
patient so it's quite confusing
which is why radiologists trained for
years to be able to do this
the setup is we'll take an input image
of someone's chest x-ray and output the
binary label 0 1 which indicates the
presence or the absence of pneumonia and
here we use a 2d convolutional neural
network which is pre pre trained on
imagenet ok so we looked at short good
connections earlier and dense Nets had
this idea to take short cut connections
to the extreme it says what happens if
we connect every layer to every other
layer instead of just connecting sort of
one instead of having just one short cut
which is what ResNet had and dense net
beat the previous state of the art and
has generally lower error and fewer
parameters on the image net challenge so
that's what we used for the data set
when we started working on this project
which was around October of last year
there was this large data set that was
released by the NIH hundred thousand
chest x-rays and this was the largest
public data set at the time and here
each x-ray is annotated with up to 14
different pathologies and the way this
annotation works is there's an NLP
system which reads a report and then
outputs for each of several pathologies
whether there is a mention whether there
is a negation like not pneumonia for
instance and then annotates accordingly
and then for a test set we had four
radiologists here at Stanford
independently annotate and tell us what
they thought was going on in those
x-rays so one of the questions
that comes up often in medical imaging
is we have we have a model we have
several experts but we don't really have
a ground truth and we don't have a
ground truth for several reasons
sometimes one of them is just that it's
difficult to tell whether someone had
pneumonia or not without additional
information like their clinical record
or even once you gave them and to be
antibiotics did they get treated so
really one way to evaluate whether a
model is better than a radiologists or
as well as doing as well as the
radiologist is by saying do they agree
with other experts similarly so that's
what we use here does the idea we say
okay let's have one of the radiologists
be the the the prediction model we're
evaluating and let's set another
radiologist to be ground truth and now
we're going to compute the f1 score once
change the ground truth do it the second
time change it again third and then also
use the model as the ground truth and do
it again and we can use a very symmetric
evaluation scheme but this time having
the model be evaluated against each of
the four experts so we do that and then
we get a score for both of them well for
all of the experts and for the model and
we showed in our work that we were able
to do better than the average
radiologist at this task two ways to
extend this in the future is to be able
to look at patient history as well and
look at lateral radiographs and be able
to improve upon this diagnosis at the
time at which we released our work on
all 14 pathologies we were able to
outperform the previous state-of-the-art
okay so model interpretation model
interpretations
yes this question that you had a future
work so almost like okay so if you have
pneumonia you present into the stalker
without like fever to talk to here with
syrup and coffee too much actually
although that's not included at the
model so thank you my question is that
if you're going to a dataset you're
trying to determine does this person
have pneumonia or that like that's one
thing but you don't sound not that you
just don't have that data but you're not
looking at other differences let's take
this out that's not cancer resemblance
to have like job other longer because
he'll call grass justice it's all those
are images that you're not really
looking at so let's say and that's been
a tough situation so the obvious
situation doesn't really give you much
to it right but the tough situation is
you get a patient that has a fever
it's coffee violently cancer or
pneumonia or black lung disease then how
do you how do you get your operative
working that condition and also if
you're not including all those other
cases then it's not just that what's the
use of it but like you'd only say yeah
and this alone so I'm trying to keep it
at this technical to the technical class
what's and is there a neural network
architecture that you would use to be
able to solve a number one it's a multi
task learning isn't it like sure sure
okay so let me try to boil those sort of
sets of questions down so one is
patients are coming in we're not getting
access to their clinical histories so
how are we able to make this
determination at all so one thing is
that when we're training the algorithm
we're training the algorithm on on
pathologies extracted from radiology
reports and these radiology reports are
written with understanding of full
clinical history and understanding of
sort of what the patient presented with
in terms of symptoms as well so we're
training the model on on these radiology
reports which had access to more
information and the second is that the
utility of this is not as much in being
able to compare a patient's x-rays day
to day as much as
here is a new patient with a set of
symptoms and can we identify things from
their chest x-rays which brings us to
model interpretation so if you were a
end-user for model oh I so when I was
back in undergrad and I was in the lab
we were working on autonomous cars and I
thought about this a lot how many of you
have been in an autonomous car how many
if you would trust being an autonomous
car yeah I thought about this as well
would I trust being an autonomous car
and I thought it'd be pretty sweet if
the algorithm that was that was in the
car would tell me whatever decision it
was going to make in advance I know
that's not possible at high speeds so
that you know just in case I disagreed
with a particular decision I could say
no abort and and half the model sort of
you know remake its decision and I think
the same holds true in healthcare as
well the one advantage that happens in
healthcare is rather than having to make
decisions within seconds like in the
case of autonomous car there is often a
larger time frame like minutes or hours
that we have and and here it's it's
useful to be able to inform the
clinician that's treating the patient to
say hey here's what my model thought and
why so here's the technique we use for
that class activation maps which you may
cover in another lecture
so I'll just I'll just leave it at
saying that there are ways of being able
to look at what parts of the image are
most evident of a particular pathology
to generate these these heat maps so
here's a heat map that's generated for
pneumonia so this x-ray has pneumonia
and I can and
and and the algorithm in red is able to
highlight the areas where it thought was
most problematic for that here's one in
which it's able to do a collapsed right
lung here's one in which Abel is able to
find a small cancer and here the goal is
to be able to improve healthcare
delivery where in the developed world
one of the things that it's useful for
is to be able to prioritize the workflow
make sure the radiologists are getting
to the patients most in need of care
before once who's x-rays look more
normal but the second part which I'm
quite excited about is to increase the
access of medical imaging expertise
globally where right now the World
Health Organization estimates that about
two-thirds of the world's population
does not have access to Diagnostics and
so we thought hey wouldn't it be cool if
we just made an app that was able to
allow users to upload images of their
off x-rays and be able to give its
diagnosis so this is still in the works
so I'll show you what we've got running
locally and so here I'm presented with a
screen that asked me to upload an x-ray
and so I have I have several x-rays here
and I'm gonna pick the one that says
cardiomegaly so cardiomegaly refers to
the enlargement of the heart so I
uploaded it now it's running the models
running in the backend and within a
couple of seconds its outputted its
diagnosis on the right so you'll see the
14 pathologies that the model is trained
on being listed and then next to them a
bar and at the top of this list is
cardiomegaly which is what this patient
has the hardest sort of
out and if I hover on cardiomegaly I can
see that the probability is displayed on
there and that we talked about
interpretation how do I believe that
this model is actually looking at the
heart rather than looking at something
else and so if I click on it I get the
class activation map for this which
shows that indeed it is focused on the
heart to be able to and and is looking
at the right thing so I guess you can
say the algorithms hearts in the right
place cool but I thought so this is an
image that I got from the the data set
that we were using NIH but it's pretty
cool if an algorithm is able to
generalize to populations beyond and so
I thought what we do is we could just
look up look up an image of cardiomegaly
and download it and just see if our
model is able to this one looks pretty
large so does this I don't want an
annotated one all right that's good so
we can do that save it desktop and now
we can upload it here
and it's already we done a thing and on
the top is cardiomegaly once again so
it's able to generalize to and there
it's the highlight so it's able to
generalize to populations beyond just
the ones it was trained on so I'm very
excited by that and what I got even more
excited by is we're thinking of
deploying this out in out in different
parts of the world and when we got an
image that showed how x-rays are read in
this hospital that we were working with
in Africa this is what we saw and so the
idea that one could snap a picture and
upload it seems and get a diagnosis
seems very powerful so the third case
study I want to take you through is
being able to look at M R so we've
talked about 1d a 1d setup where we had
an ECG signal we've talked about a 2d
setup with an x-ray how many of you
thinking of working on a 3d problem for
your project whew that's good cool so
here we looked at niyama so mrs of the
knee is the standard of care to evaluate
knee disorders and more mr examinations
are performed on the knee than any other
part of the body and the question that
we sought out to answer was can we
identify knee of normalities two of the
most common ones include an ACL tear and
a meniscal tear at the level of
radiologists now with the 3d problem one
thing that we have that we don't have in
a 2d setting is the ability to look to
look at the same same thing from
different angles and so when radio I'll
just do this diagnosis they look at
three views the sagittal the coronal and
the axial which are four to three ways
of looking through the 3d structure of
the knee and in an mr you get different
types of series based on the magnetic
fields and so there are three different
series that are that are used and what
we're gonna do is output for a
particular knee amar examination the
probability that it's abnormal the
probability of an ACL tear and the
probability of a meniscal tear important
thing to recognize here is this is not a
multi-class problem in that I could have
both types of tears
it's a multi-label problem so we're
going to train a convolutional neural
network for every view pathology pair so
that's nine convolutional networks and
then combine them together using a
logistic regression so here's what each
convolutional neural network looks like
I have a bunch of slices within a view
I'm gonna pass each of them to a feature
extractor I'm gonna get an output
probability so we had a thousand four
hundred knee mr exams from the Stanford
Medical Center and we tested on 120 of
them where the majority vote of three
subspecialty radiologists established
the ground truth and we found that we
did pretty well on on the three tasks
and had the model be able to pick up the
different abnormalities pretty well and
one can extend these these methods of
interpretive interpretability
to to 3d 3d inputs as well so that's
what we did here okay so I I saw this I
saw this cartoon a few a few weeks ago
and I thought it was pretty funny
which is a lot of machine learning
engineers think that they don't need to
externally validate which is find out
how my model works on works on data
that's not my where my original data set
came from so there's a there's a
difference in in distribution but it's
really quite exciting when a model does
generalize to two data sets that it's
not seen before and so we got this data
set that's that's public from a hospital
in Croatia and here's how it was
different so it was a different it was a
different kind of series two different
magnetic properties is a different
scanner and it was a different
institution in a different country and
we asked okay what happens when we run
this model off the shelf that was
trained on Stanford data but tested on
that kind of data and we found that it
did relatively well without any training
at all but then when we trained on it we
found that we were able to outperform
the previous lis best reported result on
the data set so there's still some work
to be done in being able to generalize
sort of my network here that was trained
on my data to be able to work on
datasets from different institutions
different countries as well but we're
making some steps along that way remains
a very open problem for taking
yeah so we did the best we could in
terms of processing so we had so one of
the pre-processing steps that's
important is being able to get the mean
of the of the input data to be as close
to the mean of the input data that you
train up
so that was one pre-processing step we
tried when we were trying to minimize
that to say out of the box how would
this work if we had never seen this data
before how would it work on that
population so one big topic in across a
lot of applied fields is asking question
okay we're talking about models working
automatically autonomously how would
these models work in when working
together with experts in different
fields and here we ask that questions
about radiologists and about imaging
models would it be possible to be able
to boost the performance if the model
and the radiologists work together and
so that's really the set up a
radiologists wit model is that better
than the radiologists by themselves and
here's how we set it up we said let's
have experts read the same case twice
separated by a certain set of weeks and
then see how they would perform on the
same set of cases and what we found that
we were able to increase the performance
generally with a significant significant
increase in specificity for ACL tears
that means if someone if a patient came
in without a without an ACL tear I'd be
able to find it better so in the future
yes question
the opinion of the radiologists art is
that that intended thing that one kind
of bias anything import actually looks
at the Commission's out yeah so that's a
good question and I and I think how so
the sort of automation bias captures a
lot of this and that once we have sort
of models working with experts together
can we expect that the experts will sort
of take it less seriously that's that's
a big concern and start relying on what
the model says and says I won't even
look at this exam I'm just going to
trust what the model says blindly that's
absolutely possible in a very open area
of research some of the ways that people
have tried to address it is to say you
know what I'm gonna do from time to time
I'm going to pass in an exam to the
radiologist for which I'm going to flip
the answer and I'll know the right one
and if they get that wrong I'll alert
them that you're relying too much on the
model stop but there are a lot of more
sophisticated ways to go about
addressing automated bias and as far as
I know it's a very open field of
research especially as we're getting
into deep learning assistants and one
utility of this is to say basically that
the set of patients don't need follow-up
let's not send them for unnecessary
surgery great so I shared three case
studies from lab the final thing I want
to do is to talk a little bit about how
you can get involved if you're
interested in applications of AI to
healthcare so the first is the ability
for you to just get your hands dirty
with datasets and and be able to try out
your own model so we have from our lab
released the Morra dataset which is a
large data set of bone x-rays and the
task is to be able to tell if it's if
the x-rays are normal or not and they
come from different
parts of the of the upper body and
that's that's what the dataset x-rays
look like and this is a pretty
interesting setup because you have more
than one view more than one angle for
the same body part for the same study
for the same patient and the goal is to
be able to combine this well into
convolutional neural network and and be
able to output the probability of
abnormality and one of the interesting
things here for transfer learning as
well is do you want to train the models
differently per body part or do you want
to train them train the same model for
body parts or combine certain models
it's a lot of design decisions there and
this is what train some train models
look like this is a model baseline that
we released that's able to identify a
fracture here and a piece of hardware on
the right and you can download the data
set of our website so if you google
Maura data set or go on our website
Stanford ml group github I oh you should
be able to find it the second way to get
involved is through the AF for
healthcare bootcamp which is a two
quarter long program that our lab runs
which provides students coming out of
classes like 2:30 an opportunity to get
involved in research and here's students
receive training from PhD students in
the lab and medical school faculty to
work on structured projects over two
quarters and if you have a background in
sir AI which you do then you're
encouraged to apply and we're working on
a wide set of problems across radiology
EHR Public Health and pathology right
now this is what the lab looks like we
have a lot of fun
and the applications for the bootcamp
starting in the winter are now open so
the early applications deadline is
remember 23rd and you can go on this
link and and and apply so that's my time
thank you so much for having me and
thanks for having me can yes I'll take a
couple questions you asked a question
about privacy concerns in terms of other
ethics concerns
what about compensation for the medical
experts figures potentially putting out
of business with a rule like the one day
you're you're developing or you know and
just in general because their their
knowledge is being used to train these
models it's not free
yeah so the question was we're having
these automated AI models trained with
the knowledge of medical experts what
are ways in which we're thinking of
compensating these medical experts right
now or in the future when we have
possibly automated models I think a lot
of people are thinking about these
problems and working on them right now
there are a variety of approaches that
people are thinking about in terms of
economic incentives and there's a lot of
fear about sort of well AI actually work
with or augment experts in whatever
field they're working on I don't have a
great silver bullet for this but I know
there's there's a lot of work going on
in there when you're eating through MRIs
we show looking at four or five category
of issues like one of them is most
likely it's possible that a human
looking at it could point out something
that was not being looked at by the AI
model at that time yeah so how do you
yeah that's a great question so that
just to repeat the question
it's we have we're looking at M our
exams and we're
saying from these three pathologies were
able to output the probabilities what
happens if there's another pathology
that we haven't looked at so I have a
couple of answers for that the first is
that one of the one of the categories
here was simply to tell whether it was
normal or abnormal so the idea here is
that the abnormality class will capture
a lot of different pathologies there at
least the ones seen at Stanford but it's
often the case that we're building for
one particular pathology and then
there's obviously a a burden on the the
model and the model developers to be
able to convey hey look our algorithm
model only does this and you really need
to watch out for everything else that
the model doesn't cover
maybe that's the unless there's one more
question no all right that's the last
question we'll take then thank you once
again so now you've got you've got the
the perspective is the microphone
working yeah now you've got the
perspective of may I researcher working
in healthcare now you are going to be
the AI research researcher working in
healthcare we're going to go over a case
study that is targeted at skin disease
so you know in order to detect skin
disease sometimes you take pictures
microscopic pictures of cells on your
skin and then analyze those pictures so
that's what we're going to talk about
today so let me talk about the problem
statement your deep learning engineer
and you've been chosen by a group of
healthcare practitioners to determine
which parts of a microscopic image
corresponds to a cell okay so here's how
it looks like on the the black and white
it's not a black and white image it's a
color image which looks black and white
the input image is the one that is
closer to me and the yellow one is the
ground truth that has been labeled by a
doctor let's say so what you're trying
to do is to segment those cells on this
image and we
talk about segmentation yet or a little
bit segmentation is is about producing
value a class for each of the pixels on
our image so in this case each pixel
would correspond to either no cell or
cell zero or one and once we output a
matrix of zeros and ones telling us
which pixels correspond it to a cell we
should get hopefully a mask like the
yellow mask that I overlapped with the
input image does that make sense yeah
color image the other one you don't have
the boundaries for yourself yeah we'll
talk about the boundary later but right
now assume it's a binary segmentation so
0 & 1
no cell and cell okay so it's going to
be very interactive and I think we're
going to use Monte for several question
and group you guys into groups of three
so here are other examples of images
that were segmented with a mask now
doctors have collected 100,000 images
coming from microscopes but the images
come from three different microscopes
there is a type a Type B n type C
microscope and the data is split in
between these three as 50% for type a
25% for type B 25% for type C the first
question I'll have for you is given that
the doctors want to be able to use your
algorithm on images from the microscope
of type C this microscope is the latest
one it's the one that is going to be
used widely in the field and they want
your your network to work on this one
how would you split your data set into
trained dev and test set as a question
and please group in teams of two or
three and discuss it for a minute on how
you would split this data set
you can start going on men's Ian and
write down your answers as well okay so
take a 30 seconds to input your your
insights on on mentee you can do one per
team
and we'll start going over some of the
answers here
okay the f-test sleaze split see train
on a plus B 20k in train 2.5 in Devon
test training 80 on a all the 5k see
deaf 10k see test 10k see 95 5 where
tests and them is from population we
care about I think these are good
answers I think there is no perfect
answer to that but two things to take
into consideration you have a lot of
data so you probably want to split it
into 95 5 closer to that than 260 2020
and most importantly you want to have
see images in the test dev and test set
to have the same distribution among
these two that's what you've seen in the
third course and we would prefer to have
actually see images in the train set
you want your algorithm to have seen see
images so I would say you're very good
answer is is this one 1955 where the
five and five are exclusively from
see and you also have see images in the
90% of train images any other insights
on that what your grease yeah how do we
attack that like microscopes Nvidia
doesn't have my hidden you know features
that mess up any yeah so there is much
more thing we didn't talk about here one
is how do we know what's the
distribution of microscope a images and
microscope images versus microscope see
do they look like each other if they do
all good if they don't how can we how
can we make sure the model doesn't get
bad hints from these two distributions
another thing is data date augmentation
we could augment this dataset as well
and try to get as much as C distribution
images as possible we're going to talk
about that okay speed has to roughly be
95 5 not 60 20/20 distribution of dev
and test sets has to be the same contain
images from CN there also there should
also be see images in the training set
now talking about date augmentation do
you think you can augment this data and
if yes give only 3ds things method you
would use if no xsplit explicate explain
why you cannot you want to take 30
seconds to talk about it with your
neighbors
okay okay guys let's go over some of the
answers so rotation zoom blur I think
looking at the images that we have from
the cells this might work very well
rotation zoom blur translation
combination of those stretch symmetry
like probably a lot of those work a one
follow-up question that I'll have is can
you can someone give an example of a
task where the augmentation might hurt
the model rather than helping it
if you want to overfeed on the test set
can you be more precise like then you
don't want to generalize oh you don't
want your model to generalize too much
okay yeah that did there's some cases
where you don't want them what model to
generalize too much especially no to an
encoder but any any other ideas you're
doing like face detection move on the
face be like upside down or like either
side I see so if you do face detection
you probably don't want the face to be
upside down although we never know
depending on the use but it's it's not
gonna help much if the camera is always
like that and it's filming humans that
are not upside now and yeah but I don't
think it's gonna hurt the model it's
probably going to not help the model I
guess yeah if you really stretch the
image so there's our algorithms like
maybe you know flow net it's an
algorithm that that's used for long
videos to detect the speed of the car
let's say if you stretch the images
probably you cannot detect the speed of
the car anymore any other examples
[Music]
character recognition I think it's a
good example so let's say you you're
trying to detect pcs and you do
symmetric flip and you get that you know
like your your labeling is be everything
that was D and as d everything that was
B for nine and six it's the same story
so these data augmentations are actually
hurting the model because you don't real
able when you data when you match your
data right okay okay so yeah many
augmentation methods are possible
cropping adding random noise changing
contrast I think the atomic chain is
super important I remember a story of of
a company that was working on a
self-driving cars and and also virtual
assistants in cars you know like this
type of interaction you have with
someone in your car a virtual assistant
and they noticed that the speech
recognition system was actually not
working well when the car was going
backwards like no idea why like why is
this doesn't seem related to the speech
recognition system of the car and they
test it out and they looked and they
figured out that people were putting
their hands in the passenger seat
looking back and talking to the virtual
assistant and because the microphone was
in the front the voice was very
different when you were talking to to
the back of the car rather than the
front of the car and so they used date
augmentation in order to augment their
current data they didn't have de town
that type of of people talking to the
back of the car so by augmenting smartly
you can change the voices so that they
look like they were used by someone who
was talking to the back of the car and
then solve the problem okay
small question we can do it quickly what
is the mathematical relation between NX
and NY so remember we have an RGB image
and we can we can flatten it into a
vector of size n X and the output is a
mask of size and Y what's the
relationship between NX and NY someone
wants to go for it
yeah three boys their equality
who thinks they record good things
they're not equal and why because you
have RGB on this side and why would be 3
and X I saw n X will be 3 and Y because
you have RGB images and for each RGB
pixel you would have 1 output 0 or 1 ok
that was a question on one of the
midterms was a complicated question
what's the last activation of your
network sigmoid you want probably an
output 0 & 1 and if you had several
classes so later on we will see we can
also segment per DC's then you would
have the softmax what loss function
should we use I'm going to give it to
you to go quickly because we don't have
too much time you're going to use a
binary cross-entropy loss over all the
outputs the entries of of the outputs of
your network doesn't make sense
so always think the thinking through the
last function is interesting ok so you
have a first try and you've coded your
own neural network that you've yelled f2
you've named model n1 m1 and you've
trained it for a thousand eight bucks it
doesn't end up performing well so it
looks like that you give it the input
image through the model and get an
output that is expected to be the
following one but it's not so one of
your friends tells you about transfer
learning and they they tell you about
another labelled data set of 1 million
microscope images that have been labeled
for skin disease classification which
are very similar to those you want to
work with from microscope C so a model
m2 has already been trained by another
research lab on this new data set on a
10 class disease classification and so
here is an example of input output of
the model you have an input image that
probably looks very similar to the ones
you're working on the network has a
certain number of layers and
softmax classification at the end that
gives you the probability distribution
over the disease that seems to
correspond to this image so they're not
doing segmentation anymore right
they're doing classification okay so the
question here is going to be you want to
perform transfer learning from M 2 to M
1 what are the hyper parameters that you
will have to tune it's more difficult
than it looks like so think about it
discuss with your neighbors for a minute
try to figure out what are the hyper
parameters involved in this transfer
learning process
okay take 15 more seconds to wrap it up
okay let's see what you guys have
learning rate it is a hyper parameter I
know if it's specific to the transfer
learning weights of the last layers so I
don't think that's a high parameter
weights are parameters new cost function
for additional output layers I think
that's the hyper that the choice of the
loss you might count it as a high
parameter I don't think it's
specifically related to transfer
learning you will have to train with the
loss you've used on your model m1 number
of new layers yeah
weights of the new not a hyper parameter
okay last one or Twitter layers of M -
so do we train what do we fine-tune it's
a lot about layers actually size of
added layers not sure okay let's go over
it together because it seems that
there's a lot of different answers here
you try to write it down here so let's
say we have we have the model M - is it
big enough for the back we have the
model M - and so we give it an input
image okay input and the model M 2 gives
us a probability distribution softmax so
we have a soft max here you will agree
that we probably don't need the softmax
layer we don't want it we want to do
such segmentation so one thing we have
to choose is how much of this
pre-trained network because it's a
pre-trained network how much of this
network do we keep let's say we keep
these layers because they probably know
the inherent salient features of the
data set like the edges of the cells
that were very interested in so we take
it so we have it here and you agree that
here we have a first high parameter that
is L the number of layers from m2 that
we take now what other hyperparameters
do we have to choose this is L we
probably have to add a certain number of
layers here in order to produce our
segmentation so there's probably another
hyper parameter which is l0 how many
layers do I stack on top of this one and
remember these layers are pre-trained
but these ones are randomly initialized
that make sense so too hyper parameters
anyone see the third one
the third one comes when you decide to
train this new network you have the
input image give it to the network get
the output segmentation mask
segmentation mask let's say sag mask and
what you have to decide is how many of
these layers will I freeze how many of
the pre train layers I freeze probably
if you have a small data set you'd
prefer keeping the features that are
here freezing them and focusing on
retraining the last few layers so there
is another high parameter which is how
much of this will I freeze LF what does
it mean to freeze it means during
training I don't train these layers
I assume that they've been seeing a lot
of data already they understand very
well the edges and less complex features
of the data I'm going to use my new my
small data set to Train the last layers
so three hyper parameters l l0 and LF
that makes sense
okay so this is for transfer learning so
it looks more complicated than the
question the question was more
complicated and it looked like okay
let's move where am i okay let's go over
another question okay so this we did it
now it's interesting because here we
have an input image and in the middle we
have the output that the doctor would
like but on the right you have the
output of your algorithm so you see that
there is a difference between what they
want and what we're producing and it
goes back to someone mentioned it
earlier there is a problem here how do
you think you can correct the model
and/or the data set to satisfy the
doctor's request so the issue with with
this image is that they want to be able
to separate the cells among them and
they cannot do it based on your
algorithm it's still little hard there
is there's something to add so can
someone come up with the answer or do
you want to explain actually you mention
one of the answers so that we we can
finish this lecture
now it looks like you could have like
three cells on the bottom left blurring
it together it and so if you ask for
adding boundaries it makes the cells
more well-defined good answer so one way
is when you label your datasets
originally you label it with zeros and
ones for every pixel now instead you
will label with three classes zero one
or boundary likes let's say 0 1 2 4
boundary or even the best method I would
say is that for each pixel for each
input pixel the output will be the
corresponding okay this one is not good
the corresponding label like this is a
sell picture he off sell P of boundary
and P of no sell what you will do is
that instead of having a sigmoid
activation you will use a soft max
actuation okay and the soft max will be
for a pixel one other way to do that if
it still didn't work doesn't work even
if you label the boundaries what is
another way to do that
Yury label your datasets by taking into
account the boundaries the model still
doesn't perform what I think it's all
about the waiting of the last function
it's likely that the number of pixels
that our boundaries are going to be
fewer than the number of pixels that
ourselves or no cells so the network
will be biased towards predicting cell
or no cell instead what you can do is
when you compute your loss function your
loss function should have three terms
one binary cross entropy let's say for
no cell 1 4 cell and one 4 boundary okay
and this is going to be summed over I
equals 1 to N I the whole output pixel
values what you can do is to atribute a
coefficient to each of those alpha beta
or 1 and by tweaking its coefficient if
you put a very high a very low number
here in the
it means you're telling your model to
focus on the boundary you're telling the
model model that if you miss the
boundary it's a huge penalty we want you
to train by figuring out all the
boundaries that's another trick that you
could use one question on that yeah good
question what do I mean by really really
willing your dataset this this last try
this section you've been labeling
bounding boxes you know for the yellow
algorithm so the same tools are
available for segmentation where you
have an image and you would draw the
different lines in practice if the more
if the tool that you were using the line
used will just count as a cell
everything including the language with
everything inside what you draw plus the
boundary would count as cell and the
rest has no cell it's just a line of
code to make it different the line you
drew will count as boundary everything
inside will count as cell and everything
outside would count as no cell so it's
the way you use your labeling tool
that's all I think it's not learnable
parameters it's more hyperparameters to
tune you know the same way you tune
lambda for your regularization you would
tune alpha and beta so when you make it
so this is not an attention mechanism
because it's just a training trick I
would say you cannot know how much
attention we tell you for each image how
much the model is looking at this board
versus that part this is not going to
tell you that it's just a training trick
what's the advantage to doing it this
way suppose like object detection like
the tank thing so the question is what's
the advantage of the segmentation rather
than detection yeah so detection means
you want to output a bounding box if you
output a bounding box what you could do
is output the bounding box crop it out
and then analyze the cell and try to
find the contour of the cell but if you
want to separate the cells if you want
to be very precise segmentation is going
to work well if you want to be very fast
bounding boxes would work better and you
guys too
the way segmentation is not working as
fast as the yo logarithm works for
object detection yeah I would say that
but it's more much more precise
okay so modify the datasets in order to
label the boundaries on top of that you
can change the last function to give
more weights to boundaries or penalize
false positives
okay we have one more slide I think so
let's go over it so now the doctors they
give you a new data sets that contain
images similar to the previous ones the
difference is that each mean image now
is labeled with zero and one zero
meaning there are no cancer cells on
that image and one means there is at
least a cancer cell on this image so
we're not doing segmentation anymore
it's a binary classification image
cancer or no cancer okay so you easily
build the state-of-the-art model because
you're you're a very strong person in
classification and you achieve 99%
accuracy the doctors are super happy and
they ask you to explain the networks
prediction so given an image classified
as one how can you figure out based on
which cell the model predicts one
soprana I've talked a little bit about
that there are other methods that you
should be able to figure out right now
even if you don't know class activation
Maps so to sum it up we have an image
input image put it in your new network
that is a binary classifier and the
network says one you want to figure out
why the network size one based on which
pixels what do you do
huh visualize ways visualize the weight
what do you visualize in the words so I
think visualizing the weights is not
related to the input the weights are not
gonna change based on the input so here
you want to know why this inputs led to
one so it's not about the weight good
idea so you know after you get the one
here this is why hats
basically it's not exactly one let's say
it's point seven probability what you
can remember is that this number
derivative of Y hat with respect to X is
what it's a matrix of shape same as X
you know two matrix and each entry of
the matrix is telling you how much
moving this pixel influences Y hat you
agree so the top left number here is
telling you how much X 1 is impacting Y
hat is it or not maybe it's not if you
have a card detector and the cat is here
you can change this this pixel it's
never gonna change anything
so the value here is going to be very
small closer to zero let's assume the
cancer cell is here you will see high
number in this part of the matrix
because this this these are the pixel
that if we move them it will change Y
hat does it make sense it's a quick way
to interpret your network it doesn't
it's not too too good like you're not
gonna have tremendous results but you
should see these pixels have higher
derivative values than the others okay
that's one way and then we will see in
two weeks how to interpret neural
networks visualizing the weights
included and all the other methods okay
so gradient with respect to your model
detects cancer cells from the test set
images with 99% accuracy while a doctor
would on average perform 97% on the same
task is this possible or not
who thinks it's possible to have a
network that achieves more accuracy on
the test set than the doctor okay can
someone can someone say why you have an
explanation
okay the network probably looks at
complex things that doctor didn't say
they didn't see that's what you're
saying possibly I think there's a more
rigorous explanation so here we're
talking about Bayes they're human level
performance and all that stuff that's
when you should see it so one thing is
that there are many concepts that you
will see in course tree that are
actually implemented in the industry but
it's it's not because you know them that
you're going to understand that it's
time to use them and that's what we want
you to get to like now when I ask you
this question you have to talk think
about pacer human level accuracy and so
on so the question that you should ask
here is what was the data set labeled
what were the labels coming from if the
data set was labeled by individual
doctors I think that looks weird like if
it was labeled by individual doctors I
think it's very weird that the model
performs better on the test set then
what doctors have labeled because simply
because the labels are wrong three
percent of the time on average the
labels are wrong so you're you're
teaching wrong things to your model
three percent of the time so it's
surprising that it gets better could
happen but surprising but if every
single image of the dates that has been
labeled by a group of doctors as pronoun
I've talked about it then the average
accuracy of this group of doctor is
probably higher than one doctor
maybe it's 99 percent in which case it
makes sense that the model can beat one
doctor this is make sense so you have a
sir you're trying to approximate with
we'd like the best error you can achieve
so we're grouping grouping a cluster of
doctors probably better than one doctor
this is your human level performance and
then you should be able to beat one
doctor it's like
okay so you want to build a pipeline
that goes from image taken by the front
of your car to a steering direction for
autonomous driving what you could do is
that you could send this image to a car
detector that detects all the cars a
pedestrian detector that detects all the
pedestrians and then you can give it to
a pass cleaner let's say that cleanse
the path and outputs the steering
direction let's say so it's not n to it
and two n would be I have an input image
and I give it I want this output so a
few other disadvantages of this is is a
something can go wrong anywhere in the
model you know how do you know which
part of the model went wrong can you
tell me which part
I'll give you an image the same
direction is wrong why
good idea
looking at the different components so
what you can do is look what happens
here and there look what's happening
here and there you think based on this
image the car detector worked well or
not you can check it out do you think
the pedestrian detector worked well not
you can check it out if there is
something wrong here it's probably one
of these two items it doesn't mean this
one is good it just means that these two
items are wrong how do you check that
this one is good you can label ground
truth images and give them here as input
to this one and figure out if it's
figuring out the steering direction or
not if it is it seems that the path
planner is working what if it is not it
means there's a problem here now what if
every single component seemed to work
properly like let's say these to work
properly but there is still a problem it
might be because what you selected as a
human was wrong the path standard cannot
detect cannot get the steering Direction
correct based on only the pedestrians
and the car detection and the cars
probably need the stop signs and stuff
like that this way you know and so
because you made hand engineering
choices here your model might go wrong
that's another thing and another
advantage of this type of pipeline is
that data is probably easier to find out
at M for every algorithm rather than the
for whole the whole end-to-end pipeline
if you want to collect data for the
entire pipeline you would need to take a
car put a camera in the front like like
build a kind of steering wheel angle
detector that will measure your ceiling
wheel at every step while you're driving
so you need to drive everywhere
basically with a car that has this
feature it's pretty hard you need a lot
of data a lot of roads while this one
you can collect data of images anywhere
and label it's a label the pedestrians
on it you can detect cars by the same
process okay so these choices also
depend on what data can you access
easily or what data is harder to acquire
any questions on that you're going to
learn about convolution on your networks
now we're gonna get fun with a lot of
imaging you have a quiz into programming
assignment for the first module second
module same midterm next Friday not this
one
everything up to C for m2 will be
included in the meter so up to the
videos you're watching this week
includes TA sections and next one and
every in-class lecture including next
Wednesday's in this Friday you have a TA
section any questions on that
okay see you next week guys